en 1986 pour la première fois le Front
National et Jean-Marie Le Pen entrent à
l'Assemblée nationale et voilà ce que ça
donne Françoise de panafieux député RPR
et même violemment prise à partie
effectivement un député du Front
national à bousculer madame de Palacio
ce qui est tout à fait scandaleux
insultes grossière demande de suspension
de séance condamnation de l'absentéisme
parlementaire et surtout démarche
exceptionnelles deux députés du Front
national vont monter à la tribune
derrière le président de séance pour
surveiller le déroulement de la
procédure
seul moi seul le président de la parole
s'il vous plaît puis les amis de
Monsieur Le Pen court dans les travées
et vote à la place des députés absents
un vol de scrutin aujourd'hui 35 ans
plus tard le contraste est saisissant
tiré à quatre épingles 89 députés du
rassemblement national font leur entrée
à l'Assemblée la consigne a été donnée
par les chefs du groupe tenus correct
exigée la stratégie de la cravate a
remplacé celle du coup d'éclat merci
madame la Présidente sur le fond sur le
fond après des années à se présenter en
partie anti-système le Rassemblement
National veut démontrer sa crédibilité
vous l'avez compris nous ne souhaitons
pas être une opposition d'obstruction
mais de propositions pas une opposition
de principe et les Troupes de Marine Le
Pen ne veulent surtout pas bousculer
l'institution
la base de l'article 64 alinéa 2 et
c'est un problème je crois qu'il faut
trancher dès le début de cette mandature
et il se battent pour obtenir un maximum
de postes au Palais Bourbon première
bataille les vices présidents elles
doivent refléter la composition de
l'Assemblée avec 89 députés le RN peut y
accéder grâce aux voix macroniste le
parti de Marine Le Pen en obtient 2
monsieur Sébastien Chenu et Madame
Hélène Laporte ces deux députés peuvent
désormais présider des séances dans
l'hémicycle deuxième bataille perdue
celle-là la commission des finances sa
présidence revient traditionnellement au
premier groupe d'opposition mais toute
la gauche plus nombreuse que l'extrême
droite a fait barrage orn c'est
l'insoumis et Coquerel qui est élu
désormais le rassemblement national se
prépare à faire railler pour la
présidence des groupes d'amitié là
encore la bataille pour les places
s'annonce intense